a lo largo de kilómetros hay campos
enteros de limoneros muertos quemados
deliberadamente por criminales tú ya no
en este pueblo estas son las huellas de
los intensos combates fachadas
agujereadas ventanas destrozadas
ningún edificio se salvó de los disparos
ni siquiera esta escuela o esta iglesia
ya nadie vive en el limoncito
en 2021 este pequeño pueblo de michoacán
del sureste de méxico fue el escenario
de una guerra territorial entre el
cártel jalisco nueva generación y
carteles unidos
nos encontramos con este anciano al que
llamaremos emilio dos días a la semana a
emilio vuelve aquí para cuidar lo que
queda de su jardín
por miedo a las represalias solo bajo el
anonimato acceda a contarnos sus noches
de angustia encerrado con su familia en
este cobertizo allí donde nos
defendíamos
una bala como tres o cuatro noches
serás una cosa espantosa resbalase
responde quieras a cristalizar una que
otra que tienes calle
lo que sí me asusto es con la familia
corre y corre en todas las culturas pues
en la tristeza
30 kilómetros más al norte en el pueblo
de la ruana hipólito mora se negó a
abandonar sus limoneros al igual que sus
empleados más fieles
que el gobierno está regalando diario
pasan con armados diario en sus
camionetas como si nada pasan por aquí
nos acostumbramos a vivir así que más
podemos hacer
y aunque queramos y así así tenemos que
vivir
esta antiguo líder de un grupo de
autodefensas había intentado ahuyentar a
los grupos criminales de su pueblo en
2013 en su momento estas organizaciones
armadas despertaron esperanzas de paz en
la región nueve años después de la
mayoría de estas han desaparecido o
están corrompidas por el crimen
organizado
el crimen está presente más que nunca en
la zona siempre acompañado de escoltas
este personaje local es el blanco de los
carteles
a pesar de la presión se niega a
abandonar su pueblo natal hace unos días
uno de sus guardaespaldas fue asesinado
el sábado por la mañana nos avisaron que
ya lo habían encontrado muerto
envuelto en una cobija con dos impactos
de bala
torturado y dentro de un río allí es una
advertencia
creo yo que me está mandando el crimen
organizado otra vez michoacán el estado
con más asesinatos de mexico con más de
800 homicidios intencionales registrados
desde enero de 2022 encarna más que
nunca la derrota de las autoridades
en estas imágenes vehículos del ejército
tienen que huir de delincuentes que los
persiguen y los insultan la escena tuvo
lugar el 11 de mayo en el pueblo de
nueva italia
ante esta explosión de violencia el
exilio se convierte a menudo en la única
opción posible algunos como celia
encuentran refugio en la capital del
estado morelia tengo tres meses aquí en
la ciudad llegue desplazada por la
desaparición de mi esposo
y lo desaparecen el 22 de febrero del
2022 en la ciudad de sahuayo michoacán
porque llegó gente armado a mi domicilio
entonces no podía poner en riesgo mi
vida y la de mis hijos
y decido
regresar a mi ciudad natal celia
encontró aquí el apoyo de evangelina
quien dirige un colectivo para ayudar a
las personas que buscan a los
desaparecidos
ella también dejó su ciudad natal tras
la desaparición de su hija en 2012
empezar a tener muchas amenazas hasta
que se dijo que ella iba a ir por mí y
yo le hablé a él de atención la víctima
de lázaro cárdenas ya el fiscal que
estaba en ese tiempo
fueron a rescatar a nuestra suponía los
interceptan a ellos los balas se han
quemado una camioneta y matan a uno de
ellos y pues yo tuve que salirme de
sacar a mi hija secuestros asesinatos
desplazamientos forzados desde el inicio
del año se han registrado más de cuatro
mil delitos contra las personas en
michoacán en todo lo que hay
desplazamiento siempre se arrastra
también sea con un feminicidio con
homicidios despojó de sus pertenencias
su rancho ganado robo de todo y pues van
desplazados van sin nada
desde 2010 en el estado de michoacán en
casi 400.000 personas se han visto
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares una
crisis silenciosa que también alimenta
el éxodo a eeuu